>> Ed: FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE DOW HAS BEEN BOUNCING
AROUND AS THE PRESIDENT MADE
SOME COMMENTS THIS MORNING
ABOUT THOSE VERY STRONG JOBS
NUMBERS.
BUT ALSO THERE ARE STILL SOME
FEARS OUT THERE ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
IT’S TIME FOR OUR HEADLINER
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING
ROOM.
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS COUNSELOR
TO THE PRESIDENT.
SHE JOINS US THIS MORNING LIVE.
GOOD MORNING, KELLYANNE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> Ed: I MENTIONED I HAVE LAURA
INGLE HERE AS WELL.
I MENTIONED THE STRONG JOB
NUMBERS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THE DOW HAD BEEN DOWN MUCH
SHARPER EARLIER IN THE MORNING.
YOUR COLLEAGUE LARRY KUDLOW WAS
ON WITH STUART VARNEY ON FOX
BUSINESS AND THE DOW ROSE 400
POINTS.
DOWN 800 TO BEING DOWN 400.
WE’LL SEE HOW YOU DO ON THAT
SCORE AS YOU TALK TO US LIVE.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS YOUR
COLLEAGUE LARRY KUDLOW WAS
TALKING ABOUT STIMULUS TO THE
ECONOMY FROM THE PRESIDENT AND
REFERRED TO CASH INJECTIONS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON WALL STREET
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
CAN YOU SPELL IT OUT?
>> THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ECONOMIC ADVISORS WILL CONTINUE
TO SPELL THAT OUT.
LET’S RECITE FACTS HERE.
WE’VE HAD 35 OUT OF 39 MONTHS
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
ADMINISTRATION WHERE WE’VE HAD
AT LEAST 100,000 NEW JOBS.
200,000 IN EACH OF THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS AND THIS IS
TWO MONTHS INTO THE CORONAVIRUS.
YET OUR FUNDAMENTALS REMAIN
VERY STRONG.
IN FACT, SINCE HE WAS ELECTED
NET 500,000 MANUFACTURING JOBS,
825,000 CONSTRUCTION JOBS.
THAT’S WHY WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SHOWS UP AT THE FOX NEWS TOWN
HALL LAST NIGHT IN SCRANTON,
PENNSYLVANIA, HE IS WARMLY
RECEIVED.
THE STATE HE WON FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 28 YEARS.
BECAUSE OF MESSAGES LIKE THAT.
BIDEN WAS BAD ON NAFTA, LETTING
CHINA IN THE WTO.
BAD ECONOMIC POLICIES.
THIS PRESIDENT MAKING TRADE
DEALS THAT BENEFIT AMERICAN
WORKERS AND THE ECONOMY.
YOU ARE SEEING THE  RESILIENCE
IN OUR ECONOMY.
THE RISK FOR CORONAVIRUS IS
VERY LOW FOR MOST AMERICANS.
WE KNOW THOSE WHO HAVE
COMPROMISED SYSTEMS ALREADY,
THE ELDERLY 70 YEARS AND OLDER
ARE AT GREATER RISK.
14 DEATHS AS OF THIS MORNING
ARE TRAGIC AND THE CONDOLENCES
GO OUT TO THEIR FAMILIES.
THE PRESIDENT’S ACTION AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS AND THE TASK
FORCE WORKING 24/7 HAS MADE THE
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF
CONTAINING THIS IN THIS COUNTRY
SO FAR.
>> Ed: HE TALKED ABOUT THAT AS
THE FOX NEWS TOWN HALL.
WE’LL GET MORE ON THE
CORONAVIRUS IN A MOMENT.
HE APPEARS SOMETHING HE TRIES
TO CLEAN UP THIS MORNING.
HE SAID I WILL PROTECT YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE
JUST AS I HAVE FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS.
SLEEPY JOE BIDEN WILL DESTROY
BOTH IN SHORT ORDER AND WON’T
EVEN NOEF HE IS DOING IT.
THE PRESIDENT PROMISING HE WILL
PROTECT SOCIAL AND MEDICARE.
HE SAID THE OPPOSITE AT THE
TOWN HALL.
HE SAID IN HIS SECOND TERM
WOULD CUT SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE AND CUT ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS.
>> HE DIDN’T SAY THAT.
YOU ARE MISQUOTING HIM.
WHEN I TALKED TO HIM AFTER I
SAID THERE WERE SOME ARTICLES
AND TWITTER TRAFFIC THAT SAYS
THE FOLLOWING AND HE SAID NO,
I’M TALKING ABOUT CUTTING
DEFICITS.
>> Ed: HOW DO YOU DO THAT,
KELLYANNE?
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT BY CUTTING
PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE THE SOUND BITE AND I
WILL LET YOU REACT.
>> THE ECONOMY IS THE BEST
ECONOMY WE’VE EVER HAD.
IT IS NOTHING COMPARED TO WHAT
IT IS GOING TO BE WHEN THE
TRADE DEALS KICK IN.
>> IF YOU DON’T CUT SOMETHING
IN ENTITLEMENTS YOU WILL NEVER
DEAL.
>> WE’LL BE CUTTING BUT WE’LL
HAVE GROWTH LIKE YOU’VE NEVER
HAD BEFORE.
>> Ed: SHE SAID YOU’LL HAVE TO
CUT ENTITLEMENTS TO CUT THE
DEFICIT.
>> HE IS NOT TALKING ABOUT
CUTTING ENTITLEMENT.
HIS PRESS SECRETARY PUT OUT A
STATEMENT LAST NIGHT AND THAT’S
NOT WHAT HE WAS REFERRING TO.
HE TALKED ABOUT GROWTH.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
BOOMING ECONOMY AND ALSO TALKED
ABOUT THE DEFICIT IN TERMS OF I
LOVED ACTUALLY HIS ILLUSTRATION
THAT WE CAN HAVE A FOREIGN
COUNTRY RUNNING UP THE HILL OF
THE WHITE HOUSE TO TAKE US OVER
BUT I BALANCED THE BUDGET OR WE
REDUCED THE DEFICIT.
HE INHERITED A BIG DEFICIT.
HE MADE VERY CLEAR THE PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT EXPLODED THE DEFICIT
BEYOND ANYTHING THAT THE PRIOR
PRESIDENTS COMBINED HAD DONE.
AND THAT THIS IS A PRESIDENT
THAT NEEDS TO REBUILD THE
MILITARY.
NO JOKE.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
LEADERSHIP WE HAVE THREE
CONSECUTIVE PAY RAISES FOR
ACTIVE MILITARY AND WHAT HE HAS
DONE FOR THE VETERANS IS
INCREDIBLE.
SECRETARY OF THE VA TELLS ME
2.5 MILLION AMERICAN VETERANS
HAVE ACCESSED THE VA MISSION OR
CHOICE ACT SINCE IT WENT INTO
EFFECT OF EARLY JUNE OF LAST
YEAR.
THEY CAN ACCESS CARE IN THE
PRIVATE SYSTEM IF THEY CAN’T
GET UT THROUGH THE VA.
HE HAD TO REBUILD THE MILITARY
AND MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
EQUIPMENT THEY NEED BUT ALSO A
PAY RAISE SO THEY ARE BETTER
RESOURCED AND MORE DEEPLY
RESPECTED.
>> Laura: WE WANT TO GET TO THE
CORONAVIRUS SITUATION AT HAND.
WE ALL WATCHED THE PRESIDENT
SIGNING THAT BILL TODAY AND WE
BROKEN DOWN THE MONEY.
8.3 BILLION IS A LOT.
WE KNOW HE IS ON THE MOVE.
THE PRESIDENT HEADING TO
TENNESSEE TO SURVEY THE TORNADO
DAMAGE AND ALSO GOING TO
ATLANTA TO THE CDC TO ADDRESS
THE SITUATION.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
VISITS.
LET’S START WITH CORONAVIRUS
AND THE CDC.
>> THE PRESIDENT THIS MORNING
SIGNED THE LEGISLATION AS ONLY
A PRESIDENT CAN DO, $8.3
BILLION, BIPARTISAN IN THE
HOUSE.
SO THAT SHOWS CONGRESS CAN COME
TOGETHER WHEN THERE IS AN ISSUE
SUCH LIKE THAT.
THAT FUNDING WILL GO IN PART TO
HELP DEVELOP THE VACCINE.
WE HAVE THE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES HERE EARLIER IN THE
WEEK.
I THINK THOSE WOULD BE
COMPETITORS, GREAT
COLLABORATORS IN THE CABINET
ROOM.
YOU COVERED IT WHERE THEY’RE
TALKING ABOUT HELPING THOSE WHO
ARE ALREADY INFECTED.
IT WILL COME MORE QUICKLY AND
THE VACCINE OVER TIME WILL COME
AND GOING AS FAST AND SAFELY AS
THEY CAN OBVIOUSLY.
IN ADDITION THE STATES I THINK
THE CDC HAS A STATE GRANT
FORMULA BASED ON POPULATION AS
TO HOW THE MONIES WILL BE
DIVIDED UP AND THE STATES CAN
DECIDE WHERE THE GREATEST NEEDS
ARE.
THAT’S VERY IMPORTANT.
YOU LOOK AT A STATE LIKE
WASHINGTON WHERE THE VICE
PRESIDENT WAS WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR THERE
YESTERDAY.
EVERYONE, WASHINGTON HAS BEEN
THE HARDEST HIT AROUND THE
NURSING HOME.
THAT’S AN EXAMPLE.
THEY’LL ASSESS WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO WITH THAT MONEY VERSUS
ANOTHER STATE.
>> Ed: WE HAVE 30 SECONDS.
WE DON’T WANT TO FORGET OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS IN TENNESSEE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING THERE TO
SHOW HIS SUPPORT.
GOT 30 SECONDS.
WHAT DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE MESSAGE?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ON
THE SCENE WITH ALL THESE
NATURAL DISASTERS THROUGHOUT
THE COURSE OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
HURRICANES, TORNADOES, AND THE
LIKE.
AND HE SAID THIS WEEK HE TOLD
US I WANT TO GET TO TENNESSEE
AS SOON AS I CAN AND, OF
COURSE, HAS BEEN IN TOUCH THERE
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND OTHERS IN
NASHVILLE.
I WAS REALLY COMPELLED THIS
WEEK WHEN YOU SAW REPORTS --
EVERY NETWORK, REPORTER WOULD
BE STANDING THERE SAYING I’M
STANDING WHERE A HOUSE WAS
YESTERDAY.
I’M STANDING WHERE A FAMILY WAS
TRYING TO GET SAFE PASSAGE IN A
BATHTUB.
WE’LL BE THERE TO MOURN THE
DEAD AND TO COMFORT THEIR
FAMILIES.
WE’LL ALSO BE THERE WITH THE
FUNDING THAT IS NECESSARY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS COME THROUGH
WITH THAT AND HISTORICALLY
THROUGHOUT HIS PRESIDENCY WHEN
TRAGEDY HAS STRUCK.
>> Ed: A LOT ON THE AGENDA.
THE DOW IS ONLY DOWN 400 POINTS.
IT GOT A LITTLE BETTER AFTER
YOU STARTED TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
>> THE JOBS REPORT IS EXPLOSIVE
BEATING EXPECTATIONS.
OTHER NETWORKS ARE PREDICTING
RECESSION.
THEY’RE IN REGRESSION.
THERE IS NO RECESSION.